you had a lot of difficulty picking your
list yeah yeah because I it wasn't until
I was making by 3x3 I realized I didn't
really grow up watching a whole lot of
like variety of TV yeah
um so I really I had to actually text my
sister to be like what the [ __ ] did we
watch growing up because I legitimately
don't remember so half of that good TV
if you don't [ __ ] remember it well no
I remembered it and she reminded me
because we were both like uh what the
[ __ ] was it what is my favorite TV show
of all time I couldn't tell you I can't
remember it no no well actually it's
it's I I had a similar problem to Joey
in that I haven't I don't think I've
actually seen that many TV shows yeah
right yeah or like seen it down to like
the end or have like an emotional
attachment yeah like there's lots of
that I've seen But like they haven't
really stuck with me or they've I don't
really feel that strongly about them
yeah because let me tell you the
difference between like a TV show and an
anime anime 24 episodes one season you
can binge that in a night if you wanted
to uh you start a TV series and it's
like hey here's nine seasons of
that's an hour long true and that's like
that's like a you know a fairly
middle-length TV yeah you know if you
talk about some of the most famous TV
shows like Breaking Bad or something
that's Five Seasons That's so short in
terms of like for Americans
right so yeah so the the rule uh is that
we decided to not include any anime
because we've already done an anime
um we can do it was like a mix of
basically it was like any TV show right
so it's like a mix between like Western
cartoons like uh narrative driven like
TV shows like just TV programming we're
used to watch literally anything Series
yeah episodes yeah and so basically
anything that's not anime because it's
not anime and a movie I can name off
more anime that I've watched than whole
than the entire broad spectrum of TV
shows in every country I feel like my
list oh God's list uh could easily have
been my list I'm pretty sure I know what
God's gonna put on his and I I could
have put them on mine but I was like
God's gonna put them on his so I'll let
go and talk about it mine's gonna be
some
[Laughter]
this I definitely felt more like a
casual coming into this like than a lot
of other I watched the most TV out of
the three of us probably probably yeah
because like I discovered anime really
early I just discovered anime really
early in life so I'm like why would I
need to watch TV when I have anime guys
come on I don't know like you know
sometimes anime is great but sometimes
you need you need like a bit of Jack
Bauer 24 in your life to like spice
things up yeah I mean like I yeah I I
get that as well and I like that one of
them that's not one of them that could
be on my list really I love 24. I don't
think I've seen a single episode of 24.
24 was like the thing I watched when I
was 15 I'm like this is so funny I know
enough about 24 throws Moses but I've
never sat down on any episode is the uh
movement of uh water particles by the
way
yes
did you just come actually
yeah I mean like there's a lot of TV
shows that I've watched like I've
actually seen 24 but I've only like I've
only seen one season of 24. I've seen
like three four seasons of Lost I've
seen two seasons of house but like it
takes up so much time I've watched a lot
of TV but it's a commitment yeah I've
never I've I've really done in my
student days yeah I've already finished
TV shows right up until the end just
because there's so much
yeah that's why I had a hard time
choosing fair enough yeah well should we
leave it to
all right who's going first
I don't know who's gonna go first
oh it's you it is you Connor I guess
that works all right all right Kai bring
up Connor's three by three all right uh
for those of you in case this is your
first time you're watching a trash Chase
3x3 video we should do a quick
explanation what a three by three is
basically it's as the name suggests it's
a box three squares by three squares
nine in total and it's basically nine
whatever the the topic is in this case
TV series that you feel strongly about
or you grew up with or you really enjoy
you really like you want to share so
these a lot of these are some of my
favorites but maybe some of this is a
good story behind it all yeah that's
what it's helped me yeah yeah basically
you'll get a good idea of what that
person's personality is like based on
their three by three yeah that's mine
that's mine all right pull it up all
right pull it up come on where is it
where is it yeah
oh okay okay so I know for starters
right Gans probably put Peep Show on his
but I had to do it I had to do it to him
yeah I'm glad okay
I only know this one from the meme yeah
okay okay I'm glad that you uh put
Arcane on it yeah
I was like Conor's gonna put Arcane on
his wall that's an anime though no it's
not okay we argued before I argued it
was an anime but no one believed before
starting can I just say this is the
worst cropping I've ever seen
I did not care to hand mode
camo Kane is there any way we can see
god
dude I can't even see the title of Mad
Men because it's yeah they put this big
ass [ __ ] watermelon I'm like what the
[ __ ] whatever I I was like when looking
for mine I liked I tried to look for
like Square images
I've never seen of Kane or well I'll
explain what they're all in hunting so
let's go we're gonna how do you guys
want to do it uh just go through them
all I mean okay so actually before we
get into it I'll just tell which each
show is we'll talk about please number
one Banger Hannah Montana number two in
the the Middle top yeah top right Arcane
middle left better call Seoul middle
task master uh middle right Futurama
bottom left come dime with me bottom
middle yeah bottom right is Mad Men okay
yes I was I was walking see because I've
seen this image yes through memes let's
let's start with some dinosaurs
that triggered a response to me
um I'm assuming you didn't put it on
your list gone yes I didn't I didn't
yeah but there's a yes I did yes I did
okay yes no there are a few things here
that I very much considered putting on
uh I was very close to the funny future
Futurama very very close come down with
me as well I think is pretty much the
only I I made my list and I was like
yeah yeah you can tell I'm white without
I was like I felt like I made it and I
was like yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's
fine I am right I too enjoy Television
right so let me explain come down with
me to those who don't know it's a
British TV show and it's fantastic I
swear this thing is short on like a
budget of like a hundred dollars yeah um
they they are like one every day I don't
like understanding this works it's like
they ask so many of these goddamn
episodes how many episodes have come
down with me in the UK is that so the
the whole concept behind this TV show is
you get four strangers yeah who all are
very proud of their cooking and their
house and the idea is is that once in
this in this nice uh is it an hour or 30
minutes uh I think it's about 30 minutes
30 minutes they all go do you get a
Whopper okay this is [ __ ] let me
explain
a great explanation but I forgot do they
go to everyone's house in one episode or
they go to one person tells one episode
no it's everyone's house okay okay so
it's everyone
so it's four people competing against
each sometimes five sometimes five okay
but most of the time it's four people
and these four people going to take it
in turns to host a dinner party
and within uh within the stin party they
have to impress the guests as much as
possible not just with the food but with
the experience of their home dining
experience right right uh so sometimes
they put as much effort into like
personalize their home dining experience
as possible and at the end of the day
um each contestant rates how good their
experience was and how good the night
was
atmosphere yeah but obviously right like
you're is everyone's voting for each
other it's kind of a trust system of are
you not going to be a dick yeah give
everyone else a one because you want to
win yeah and so it kind of has a lot of
really fun elements to it a lot of snide
moments but also the best part of the
show is the cringe it's so good because
you get a bunch of just generic office
workers just normal people yeah you tell
them they're a dinner party for random
strangers on camera and it's just it's
fantastic and then they also decided and
this is probably the best part of the
show yeah they decided that they were
going to make the narrator just a guy
who just takes the piss out of
everything they do classic British is
just completely sarcastic right 24 7.
and it just keeps the show going and it
keeps you uh keeps you invested this to
me come down to me this to me is Peak
British reality TV because like I
imagine like a come dine with me in
America God every time I say come now I
can't I can't
calm down with me oh my God like every
if I imagine like can you imagine an
American come down with me it'll be like
it would be like the most over the top
[Music]
overcooked the chicken
it's great there's like there's very
minimal editing it's really strong it's
really stale it's like the the thing
that shines about this is just British
sarcasm and Sass because they never say
that they have a bad experience with the
meal yeah but that's what makes it good
right how do you how would you not
insult the uh the host of this dinner
party while we're while still insulting
the host of this dinner party right it's
[ __ ] fantastic and like most of the
time it's like four very average or
below average Cooks just giving each
other [ __ ] right for knocking I feel
like I've definitely seen Clips yeah
it's really good and
things what were they like while the
person's cooking I'm pretty sure the
producer's like hey go and Snoop around
their house and look at things and
comment and they just like raid each
other's houses it's so bizarre but it's
really fun and I do oh my God it's just
the the amount of bickering and just
bitchiness involved which is fantastic
and it's just so like surface level yeah
like a concert they don't ever say it
they'll be like well Timothy's quiche
was rather cold so I'm gonna have to
dock five points for that and it's like
what what do you mean like you're making
[ __ ] up like you just made it up or like
someone be like the food was all amazing
and one person would be like actually I
hated it it was not the difference it's
like you're right it was it sucked I
think there's one clip where someone
actually did properly go off like there
was actually drama and it's one of my
favorite like television clips of all
time she's like like because a guy was
like really really salty that someone
else had won right and by the way oh
I've I know this he stands up right and
he stands up but yeah by the way the
winner they only get like a hundred quid
or something
right it doesn't even cover the cost to
cook the [ __ ] food people are playing
for pride and there's there's one clip
once one guy gets so [ __ ] salty that
someone else wins and it's like one of
my favorite moments in TV because he
because he just starts like it's the
most British insults that he just starts
throwing out and he just goes well Phil
three to get the [ __ ] out of my house
you reverse out of this like uh you
reverse you reverse you know you walk
with the grace of a dump truck or
something like that it was so good can
we play the clip we don't play with that
video you're wondering enjoy the money
but I hope now you spend it on getting
some lessons in Grace and decorum
because you have all the grace of a
reversing dump truck without any tires
on oh my God it's it's just fantastic
and it's just like if to me it's what
reality TV should be right yeah it's
like none of this like ruins someone's
life or just make them [ __ ] miserable
or just sell sex sex sex sex it's like
let's just get people to cook for each
other and just let them do like just
give them the tools to have their own
destruction like just saying hey rate
their food right and just see what
happens and it's fantastic I think
there's like a bazillion episodes yeah
there is 151 episodes
[Music]
1051. 1051 episodes yeah basically you
know you know that TV show that just
always seems to be always on this every
day this is always on in one channel or
another if it's not on like channel four
then it's on one of like the reruns of
like one of the other channels it
doesn't matter I'm surprised it even has
Seasons like it's really good yeah it's
very and this is that this is where that
iconic uh meme comes from where the guy
puts the the uh The Colony
but it's like it sums up like home
cooking I'll just do it my way yeah